[Music]
hello this is susan from san antonio
texas
i have enjoyed every episode
and a friend of mine gifted me last
christmas
an april 1972 issue of cosmopolitan
magazine
and i am sure you know burt reynolds
was the centerfold was the first
centerfold for the magazine so my
question
to you rob lowe is if given the
opportunity
would you pose for a centerfold
asking for a friend thank you love your
podcast
hey susan you're telling me you have
an original cosmo with burt reynolds
centerful in it
i would give a lot of money for that
that's a big
deal i'm not kidding that's a that is an
iconic
piece of show business you have in your
hot little hands
so don't lose it it's a big deal
i mean kudos your friend who gave that
to you um
[Music]
i would absolutely do particularly i
would absolutely do a centerfold
particularly if it were
a parody of the reynolds one i believe
there's a bearskin rug involved or a
tiger skin rug
and a fire behind him um
and you know when i was younger and like
an ingenue
and a pin-up um i would have chafed
at i'm not going to allow myself to be
objectified
in such a way i'm more than my body
57 years old now [ __ ] it
you know what i mean it's like i will
throw down
[Music]
use it or lose it you know what i'm
saying
so um if the opportunity comes my way
i'm down to clown